We are being told this morning
that Trump's
defense team is likely to attack
the credibility of a major witness
in the Manhattan
district attorney's case.
Michael Cohen,
the former Trump lawyer,
was convicted of lying to Congress,
among other financial crimes.
He says, are you pled guilty to that?
We should note.
He says he is proof this morning
that he is telling the truth here
I am a convicted felon
and I am a disbarred lawyer, but
I also brought the documents.
There's plenty of testimony,
corroborating testimony to go around.
And at the end of the day,
we have an indictment today.
So clearly
that means that the information provided
was more than enough for the grand jury.
To come back
with the determination
for an indictment or,
by the way,
for Donald,
since we're talking about
convicted felons.
See, on Tuesday, pal. Hmm.
Joining us now is Jim Trusty.
He is a current attorney for Trump
and the Department of Justice
probe into the 2020 election,
as well as the investigation
involving classified documents
at Mar a Lago
Good morning, Jim,
and thank you for being here.
You're not representing Trump
in this Manhattan case,
we should make clear.
But you are on his legal team.
Obviously,
you spent a lot of time with him.
Do you expect that he's actually
going to surrender himself on Tuesday,
as we've been talking about
Yeah, I don't have any inside
info to share on that.
I mean, we'll sort through it.
We'll deal with the process.
I think right now
we're dealing
with the enormity of the injustice
and the shock of seeing people
like Michael Cohen
touted as credible witnesses.
Or maybe he'll have Avenatti
as a character witness. I don't know.
But it's a really astounding,
astounding bad moment
in the history of this country.
Why do you say that?
Because we've got
a completely politicized prosecution.
You know, your last segment,
you had folks
that actually talked
openly about CNN appearances
by Alvin Bragg
running for camp for office, saying,
I will target Donald Trump.
I mean,
that is not something
to gloss over lightly.
That is an upside down
world of criminal justice.
Where we don't follow evidence,
we don't act judiciously as prosecutors.
And I was a prosecutor for 27 years.
Okay. So I have some background on this.
You've got people
that are announced politically
they're going to target an individual.
That is not the rule of law.
That is not what this country
was built upon.
And so when you talk about Donald Trump
being angry, he should be mean.
I'm amazed he's not,
you know, more apoplectic.
But he is right to be angry
at political persecution,
which is what this case is.
Is he angry?
Have you spoken to him?
Since this indictment happened?
No, I don't talk
about that kind of stuff. Sorry, Kaitlyn.
What's your sense of what happened?
How about that?
What's your sense
of what happens between now and Tuesday?
Well, look, you know, I'll tell you,
the big picture is,
you know, if you're representing him
on the New York case,
you've got a lot of stuff
to be focusing on.
But one of them
is going to be pretrial motions.
I know Ali, in the earlier segment
talked about how
that's a part of the process.
You know,
you don't usually win
on a pretrial motions saying, hey,
the government's got the worst witnesses
imaginable.
Even if that happens to be true,
you win on legal issues.
And this case is all about.
It looks like from the outside
right now, mental gymnastics
that don't add up.
I mean, legal gymnastics,
they're going to fall apart.
So I would think in very short order,
you'll see a motion to dismiss
or several motions
to dismiss
Talking about this
kind of impossible theory
of stacking a federal crime
into a state misdemeanor
statute of limitations issues
and very importantly,
the intent to defraud.
That's an element
of these false recordkeeping charges
that's just not present here
under even the most dreamy
of Michael Cohen moments.
It's not part of the case.
So there's a lot to look at.
I think there'll be pretrial motions
that will be hugely important
and well-founded
to dismiss this travesty,
those motions to dismiss that.
You say you're expecting
will those come before
the indictment is unsealed on Tuesday,
or what is your expectation there?
I don't know about the exact timing.
I think the practical problem is,
you know,
we don't even have a case number.
Keep in mind, with Donald Trump,
there are no rules.
So, once again,
we have sealed proceedings
that have been leaked publicly
that we're all talking about.
I mean, it's
just kind of an amazing breakdown
of due process and fair play.
So we don't even have a case number
at this moment. But it'll be soon.
I think this will be something
you can expect in days or weeks.
Not not weeks or months.
Okay.
So you say there will likely be a motion
to dismiss this. That's important.
You are representing Trump
in the January six investigation
in the classified documents
investigation.
There are several
investigations now
facing him,
including with this indictment.
How does the legal team manage
all of these investigations at once?
Well, we've got a good team.
We've got a lot of different people
with a lot of different backgrounds
and experience.
You know, I will say
the one common thread
that I'm seeing is somebody
who was associated with DOJ for 17 years
and watching what's happening
unfolding in New York
is prosecutorial overreach.
You know, there's an ends
justify the means mentality
that is unlike anything
I've ever seen in prosecutorial circles.
You've got people like Letitia James
now, Alvin Bragg
announcing we will get him.
You've got an attorney general
the United States doing press conferences
after a search warrant,
which is completely unprecedented,
unprecedented and unethical.
And so what we do is, you know,
we kind of shadow
the investigations,
figure out the actual facts
and find ways to litigate, often
under seal.
Some of the issues that are just rolling
through these over
these heavy handed investigations
into the president,
you know, he's got plenty of resources
to bear to fight back.
You noted all the attorneys
here on the team.
How many how many exactly are there
how many attorneys are there representing
Trump at this time?
Oh, I don't I don't
have an exact number for you.
So when the war
when you talk about all
and Bragg and Trump
has continued to attack him,
he faced criticism over the weekend
after there was a link
that he posted on Troop
Social that a photo of Trump
holding a baseball bat
next to a picture of Alvin Bragg.
Is it inappropriate for the
for your client to post things like that,
attacking the district attorney,
calling him an animal,
calling him a racist?
Well, as I understand it,
the meme that got retweeted
didn't actually have the image
until it showed up on true social.
So he didn't actually know
that there was this
baseball bat image thing.
It's unfortunate that that happened.
And there's a lot of room
for an emotional reaction from anybody.
Any client
I have would be angry at this point.
But the general concern
that President Trump has,
and I think it's a very genuine one,
is that this is not even just about him.
Yes, he's being targeted
for political persecution,
but this is an attack on the fabric
of our system,
on the whole presumption
of innocence, due process,
prosecutorial ethics.
I mean, all of this is in play
under that category of rule of law.
And I'm as frustrated as anyone
to see this kind of change in a system
that heretofore
had been the best in the world.
You're representing Trump
on the classified documents matter.
Did he still know
that there were documents,
still classified documents,
still at Mar a Lago
after a subpoena came
to return those documents
I'm not going to get into the facts
of any investigation that's pending.
What I can tell you is
you can't say whether or not
the United States is there
Caitlin, do you really expect
that we're going to have
that kind of conversation?
I think you know better.
But the reality is
the president has every right.
We entrust presidents
under the Constitution
to know state secrets, to be familiar
with these things,
to even hold on
to documents and determine
which ones they're going to hold on to
and which ones
they're going to give to the archives.
So criminalizing that process was absurd.
That's nothing
that's ever happened in history.
You've got thousands
of classified documents
sitting in Chicago
for the Obama Foundation.
No similar treatment.
And that's really
what President Trump is fighting about.
And that's what we're fighting about
is the idea that somehow
this whole criminal justice system
can be turned on its head because of him.
You know,
one person gets differential treatment
across the board,
whether it's criminalizing
a civil dispute about documents,
whether it's ignoring
peaceful words on January six
or threading together
this ridiculous misdemeanor
through the worst credible,
the least credible witnesses.
You can imagine in New York,
it's only him.
He's the only one
that gets that treatment.
And we're going to fight back hard.
Well,
I think it's fair question to ask, given
the Justice Department
wanted those documents back
and we've seen the fight that played out
that Jim, trustee representing
President Trump right now.
Thank you for joining us this morning.
Thank you for your time
to talk about these
investigations facing Trump.